>>presenter: It's a great honor today to introduce
Rainn Wilson, the co-author of "SoulPancake,"
and you also may have figured out he also
plays Dwight from the series "The Office."
I'd like to read a quote from the introduction,
just to set the stage for him. "I believe
art and its expression are the same as faith
and its expression; science, too, for that
matter. And quite frankly, everything that
urges us to create, to love, to think deeply,
to breathe in the moment, to be of service
and to be human." Also joining us is Rainn's
friend and to help us guide us all in this
quest and discussion is Will Eno, who is a
Guggenheim Fellow and also a finalist for
the 2005 Pulitzer Prize in Drama. His new
play, Middletown, was the winner of the 2010
Horton Foote Award and premiered at the Vineyard
Theatre in New York this November. The authors
will also sign books after the talk, but no
memorabilia, please. And for the Q and A period,
please use the microphones queued up in either
aisle way. Don't shout from your seats. Without
further ado, ladies and gentlemen, please
help me in welcoming Rainn and William to
Google New York.
[applause]
>>Rainn: Yeah! Yeah!
[applause and cheering]
What?
That's what I imagined a motivational speaker
would do.
[laughter]
>>Will: That is nice, funny. It's very nice
to be here. I'm a tiny bit nervous; I don't
normally do things like this and I might have
killed a cop on the way over here, so I'm
a little uneasy.
[laughter]
But it's very nice to be here. I've known
Rainn for 20 years and looking around, I see
a lot of youngish people and I just was thinking
it's good to keep in mind that you do end
up, if you're friendly and you live and you
don't die, you end up knowing people for 20
years and--
[laughter]
so, if you're loving and good, as Rainn has
always been, then people remember that for
20 years. And I'm sure--
>>Rainn: I have not died in the last 20 years.
[laughter]
>>Will: I know. Twice.
>>Rainn: Yeah.
[Rainn laughs]
>>Will: But, how about, you touch on it quite
a bit in the introduction, but how about talking
a little bit about other places that you've
been in your life, other than where you are
now, with respect to the world and big things.
>>Rainn: Well, that's an interesting segue.
I was not always amazing.
[laughter]
By the way, I had to; I had to go to AskJeeves
to find out where this place was.
[laughter]
And that, no, I had to actually call my butler,
Jeeves--
[laughter]
who was on my plane and he was, he asked my
pilot to punch it in. Anyways, they eventually
Googled it and I got here. I, yeah, OK, how
do I answer that question? I believe that,
and I talk about this in my introduction to
the book, which is only the tiniest fraction
of what "SoulPancake" book is, but as I, at
the ripe old age of 44, when I look back on
my life, I see it as one enormous creative
and spiritual journey. And it's been quite
a miraculous ride and somehow or other I've
ended up here at the Google headquarters talking
about a book. How's that?
>>Will: It's good. It's good.
[laughter]
So, Rainn is a deep and dark and full sort
of figure, so I'm sure we're gonna get into
some difficult stuff, so I just want to start
that by definition of terms.
>>Rainn: Ok.
>>Will: Webster's Dictionary defines a pancake
as a thin, flat cake of batter cooked in a
pan, or on a griddle, a griddle cake, a flapjack.
Do you agree?
>>Rainn: I agree. I think--
[laughter]
I think that definition pretty much sums up
what a pancake is all about, so--
[Will laughs]
>>Will: It does, yeah.
>>Rainn: yeah. We'll go with that.
>>Will: All right. So, the book, in a great
way, the book, it's--
>>Rainn: Are there any questions?
[laughter]
>>Will: And this is great, but can we get
four of those Google phones up here? Is that
possible?
[Rainn laughs]
The book is a, it's absolutely a destination.
You can have it sitting on your table and
you can go into it, but then it also it's
a starting point, it's a really, really great
thing. It's like a very gentle game of truth-or-dare,
or something like that; that people can kick
around with.
>>Rainn: Yeah. The book is many things and
it has essays in it-- little ones. It has
lots of heart in it; it has many of life's
big questions, which I'll get to more later
as I talk about artistic and spiritual journeys,
creative journeys, technological journeys.
>>Will: You're gonna talk about that, really?
>>Rainn: No.
[laughter]
But, that's, I can't speak to that. But, yeah,
this is a lot of what we have in the book
is a lot of creative challenges. This would
be a great book for people to have to; this
would be great on a date.
[chuckles]
I'm just gonna go back to the beginning a
little bit. Hi, welcome everybody; all you
latecomers. Oh, you're too busy Googling things
up there?
[laughter]
To come and get a chair? All right, track
suit.
[laughter]
So, when I started getting well-known for
doing "The Office", I really wanted to do
something positive and unique on the Internet,
cause there's so little, there's so much crap
out there. And when I was a teenager, I was
every kind of nerd. I was even on the computer
club for awhile and I programmed in Basic
a little bit.
[cheering and clapping]
Yeah. Yes. And, but I was also in Model United
Nations and band and debate and I was on the
chess team. We were undefeated that year,
no thanks to me.
I was fifth board, so I don't know if you
know what that means. There's, you play your
top five players, OK? I was the fifth best
in Shorecrest High School in Seattle, Washington.
Woo! No one went there. And, but one of the
kinds of nerds that I was, was a philosophy
and spirituality nerd. I took a lot of great
books courses, where instead of writing papers;
we debated things and talked about big ideas.
And it was my favorite thing to do. I even,
a group of friends and I--, when I was a freshman
in college, we decided it would be a great
idea-- we discovered caffeine. There weren't
Starbucks back then and they didn't, coffee
was like, it was just like coffee farts; like
someone ate a coffee bean and farted in a
glass of water and that's what, that's what
coffee tasted like for decades.
[laughter]
And we--, so, they called it Folgers, or something
like that.
[laughter]
And so, we went this cafe in the University
of Washington, it was called Last Exit to
Brooklyn, and we drank these things called
espresso floats and they had like, triple
shots of this espresso with coffee beans churned
in there. And we didn't even know what caffeine
was or coffee beans and we would drink thing
and we would just be instantly filed with
just the most amazingly, great ideas. And
one of the great ideas we had was, "Let's
take my whole philosophy book collection,
go up to Capitol Hill and rap philosophy for
money. And we'll make enough money to back
and buy more espresso floats."
[laughter]
So, we went up there--it's a true story--
and we would rap to Rousseau and Kant and
Nietzsche and we were just out free-styling
to these philosophers. We thought it was just
the most amazing; we were just flying so high
at that point, like, "This is gonna be completely,
this is gonna be amazing. We blow people's
minds." And we had a hat out and we were making
all kinds of money and then someone stole
our hat with all our money. And we left and
then we had a caffeine crash and then it all
ended poorly. But, that's to say that, so
the stuff of what this book is, is philosophical
and creative and spiritual journeys. I was
very intrigued with, at a young age and so,
I had this great opportunity to start a website,
so pancake.com. It has like, triple the usage
of Google.
[laughter]
And it's out of the park. So, pancake.com,
and then we decided that this would be a great
companion piece to the website. So, a roundabout
way of answering Will's question is that,
this is a companion piece to the website,
but it also stands alone in that it's about
promoting discussion. There's no answers in
this book, there's no answers on the website.
Too many people know all the answers all the
time. I mean, even newscasters have the answers
to how everything should work, but it's all
about-- we realized as we were building SoulPancake,
like, it really is all about the questions.
And whether you're an atheist or you're a
born-again Christian or a Buddhist or a Sikh
or Agnostic or you've never thought twice
about it, we all have to deal with death and
love and regret and free will and family and
all of these things that present so many of
life's big questions. And so, I was just thrilled
to be able to launch something like this.
And my other, my co-writers, and my co-"SoulPancake"
team members are right here. Stand up, you
guys. Devon and Golriz and Shabnam, stand
up.
[applause]
Aren't they cute? Aren't they adorable? So,
yeah. What else?
>>Will: I'm sorry; I'm a million miles away.
Say that again.
[Rainn laughs]
[Will laughs]
>>Rainn: When I was a teenager, oh, ok.
>>Will: You reminded me that there's a great
piece of, I think this guy's sort of a Jewish
mystic type, but his quote is, "The answer
is the order of the questions." And the way
the book unfolds, and the order of the questions
in it, are, it's very nice, meaningful and
sort of gently directed experience to go through
it. Cause that's how you read this, at the
start.
>>Rainn: You start at the top.
>>Will: Yeah, I know. On the left.
>>Rainn: Who said that? Do you remember Maimonides?
Was that--
>>Will: Jabes. Edmond Jabes.
>>Rainn: Jabes.
>>Will: Who has a book called "The Book of
Questions."
>>Rainn: Oh, does he really?
>>Will: Yeah.
>>Rainn: Where can you get that. Could someone
Google that?
>>Will: Could we get four of those Google
phones up here to the microphone?
>>Rainn: Yeah, and that--
[laughter]
we categorized all the questions into nine
chapters: Brain and the Soul, Art and Creativity,
Experiences and Emotions, Love, Sex and Relationships,
Virtues and Vices, Introspection, Reflection
and Identity, God and Religion, Science and
Technology--woooo! wooooo!--
[laughter]
Life, Death and Living and Who is Gonna Replace
Steve Carell on "The Office".
[laughter]
>>Will: So, quick, some, just-, maybe people
are interested in your personal life. Is there
a Mr. Wilson in the picture, other than your
dad and like, I guess, you?
>>Rainn: My grandpa.
>>Will: Ok.
[laughter]
>>Rainn: He's dead.
>>Will: No, but you're very proud of Holly
and Walter and--
>>Rainn: Yeah, I have a wife named Holly,
who I love. We've been together for 20 years;
married for 15. And I have a son, Walter.
We've been together for six years.
[laughter]
And you remind me of me when I was that age.
And, yes, I have a family. My wife and I had
sex and we created a son.
[laughter]
>>Will: True story. No, true story.
>>Rainn: True story.
[laughter]
Basically--
>>Will: Well, no, actually well, now that
I think of it, but--
[laughter]
>>Rainn: Just to go into more detail on that,
she disrobed.
[laughter]
No. What else do you got? I would love to
get into questions. I don't really know what
else to say here.
>>Will: Yeah, but I wanna, there's something
I do want you to say, or--
>>Rainn: Yeah.
>>Will: both of us to somehow get towards
saying, but in a great way, you've always
been the way you are in a deep and real way.
But then also, or, seeds of you have-, you've
always been there in some form that has gotten
stronger and clearer and all sorts of great
things. And I don't wanna get, I couldn't
get too deep into philosophy cause I don't
know that much, but whatever we call the soul,
do you think of it as something that can increase
or progress or grow?
>>Rainn: That's interesting.
>>Will: Isn't it?
[Rainn laughs]
>>Rainn: I, the soul is a weird one and I'd
love to hear people's thoughts and if we have
a soul. I think the word "soul" is weirdly
used, cause many religious beliefs says, "We
have an eternal soul," and they have a very
specific view of what that is, I think, and
then we know what like, "soulfulness" is in
music, but there seems to be a disconnect.
I grew up a member of the Baha'i faith, and
that informed a lot of where my thirst and
my curiosity for all different religious beliefs
and philosophies came from and my parents
encouraged that. They would invite born-again
Christians into the house with the Watchtowers,
to talk about the Bible and we would have
Buddhist monks stay with us and we had books
on Egyptian mysticism and Sikhism and it was
a really fun household in that respect; other
than the fact that we all hated ourselves.
[laughter]
And then, the true story--
and then I went through a long period of time
of really questioning all that and I really
decided that there could not be a God and
that God was a construct and that only the
weak needed God and so much evil had been
perpetrated in the name of religion and how
could religion possibly be relevant to this
day and age. And that's, and I talk about
this in my introduction; I'm not gonna just
tell you the whole thing right now. But basically,
as I came through my '20s and discovered that
I was unhappy, even though I had become an
artist, which was my dream, and I moved to
New York and I shaved my head and dyed my
hair black and smoked filterless cigarettes
and I became a bohemian and I was doing off
off Broadway plays and I was doing workshops
with Andre Gregory where we were doing plastiques,
where we were doing these body deconstructions
for hours, sweating in weird lofts in the
meat packing district. And I was like, "This
is my dream come true." I was getting paid
to be an actor, I was like, "My God, I'm an
artist, I'm an actor, I'm living in New York;
this is awesome." But I was really, really
unhappy. And that, I think that's when we
all go on journeys is when we get unhappy
enough. All of a sudden, we get unhappy enough
and then the needle goes "eeeeh" and then
we go, "I need to do something about this.
I need to figure out what that is." And it
could be through therapy or through travel
or breaking up with someone or whatever we
do to kind of unravel that, but I went, then
I describe this long spiritual journey. But
basically, what, long story short is what
I came to realize is that I came back to my
faith, but more importantly, what I learned
from that journey is that it's all the same
thing. And this is supported by my faith;
I think it's supported by all the faiths in
the world. And that's what that young man
who introduced me--I'm gonna call him Chip;
I don't know what his name is--
[laughter]
>>Will: Leigh. Leigh.
>>Rainn: Don't care.
[laughter]
He--
>>Will: Terrible person. Terrible, terrible
person.
>>Rainn: He's a terrible, terrible man.
>>Will: No, you're a terrible man.
[laughter]
>>Rainn: He, oh, I am?
>>Will: What? I'm sorry. Again, I was wasting
time.
>>Rainn: So what I came back to is that it's
all the same thing. Is that my basic, my personal
belief, which really doesn't have to do with
the book--this is what I think. But it maybe
is filtered through the book a little bit,
is that there's not any difference. We, as
human beings, long to transcend. We want more
than just the material. I think even people,
even-- even Bill Maher or Christopher Hitchens,
or any of the adamant God deniers, still are
yearning for something. They still are reaching
for something; they're still doing more than
just eating and shitting and fucking and sleeping
and accruing wealth. They're wanting more
than that. They're wanting to connect. They're
wanting to create art. They're wanting to
make the world a better place. They're wanting
to increase discussion, whatever that is,
but soulfulness is, I think, human beings
wanting to transcend just the ordinary. And
that can be through making music and making
art. That can be through exploring the limits
of science and technology and mathematics
and striving to go beyond just the material
world. It can go through an expression of
prayer or devotion; to be devout. And that,
this is an expression of the soul. So, I think
that we all have souls, we all have that an
energy in us and about us that wants to do
more than just be a monkey and this soul can,
I believe, when exercised and can grow and
flourish and become more and more radiant
and that's really what life is all about.
But I don't think that you need religion necessarily
to do it. I think that you just need to, one
just needs to engage in this moment right
now, all that exists is [snaps finger] boom,
here we are and there, it's gone. And boom,
and now, now, now, and this is where we live
and that's, it's about the striving and the
striving creates soul. Oh my gosh, what'd
you do?
[laughter]
You spilled that. Was it water?
OK, good.
[chuckles]
Is there anyone here on the Google janitorial
staff?
>>Will: Can we get some paper towels and some
of those free iPhones?
>>Rainn: The Google janitorial--
[laughter]
So, I dunno. This is wierd; this is your lunch
hour? Is that what's going on? What happens
after this? You go back to work? What are
you guys working on?
[laughter]
Are any of you guys taking pictures out on
the streets of the things for the Google Maps?
[laughter]
Who here works on Google Maps? Who here works
on Google App-, Apps?
[chuckles]
Who works on the search engine? Who works
on the servers?
[chuckles]
Who works in the cafeteria? Who works on the
phone? Nobody? You do? You're the one person.
[laughter]
What else does Google do? YouTube?
>>Will: Keep going, Rainn. This is gold. This
is gold. Keep going.
[laughter]
>>Rainn: Who works, who works on YouTube's?
[Will laughs]
All right. Yeah.
>>Will: I have a thought. I saw a guy speak
last night named Slavoj Zizek. Do you know
that guy?
>>Rainn: No.
>>Will: A Slovenian philosophy guy. He wrote,
he has a great book called "In Defense of
Lost Causes," and he did a great thing called
"The Pervert's Guide to Cinema," which is
unbelievable; it's great stuff, yeah.
>>Rainn: Oh yeah, I've heard about that book,
yeah.
>>Will: But he was saying, he was quoting
Kierkegaard last night and I thought of you
and the Baha'i thing, because he was saying--
Kierkegaard said, in the 1800s or whenever
Kierkegaard was, that any divinity student,
any theology student could lay out Christianity
much better than Christ ever did; they could
describe the whole thing. It very clearly
made it all seem like just an ongoing conversation
that the world religions are this, this long,
rich, deep debate moving toward ever--I don't
know how to, I don't know what to put after
"ever," but toward clarity and toward some,
not final vision, but a fullest vision.
>>Rainn: Yeah, and the fullest vision, I think,
they-- I think religion does an awful lot
of damage in the world, but I think that religion,
I think that we as a society right now, we're
throwing the baby out with the bath water
in terms of religion; just saying like, "Well,
it's all a bunch of crap." And that's easy
to say when you see what's done in the name
of religion, but it's also easy to just throw
the baby out with the bath water and not notice
that there are some things about religious
faith that are beautiful and true and lasting.
>>Will: Yep.
>Rainn: In the same way that there are things
about science and art that are beautiful,
true and lasting. So--.
>>Will: No, that's, he also, this guy, Zizek,
also had an interesting point, which was,
and I couldn't agree more in that it seems
like that wonder is the, that's the important
thing--
>>Rainn: Mm-hmm.
>>Will: and that's not knowing and wonder
and striving toward--there must be reasons
and great, grand, beautiful reasons. But he
was saying--
>>Rainn: Well, I think that's what--hold that
thought-- what this book--
what life's big questions does, is hopefully
it engages that sense of wonder and the sense
of asking. And again, yearning and searching,
because I think that the easiest thing, I
guess what I say, what I'm all about is that
the easiest thing in the world to do is to
be cynical. It's an easiest fallback position
to know it all, to be over it, to be cut off
from, to be withdrawn from, to know better
than others, to be pissy and sarcastic and
all of those things. Like, it's a really easy
position to be in. It's actually really hard
to be present, engaged and open-hearted. And,
but I think that's what we can all aspire
to. And I think that engaging in the questions
helps us get there. Does that make sense?
You guys didn't think you were gonna get this
kind of talk, did you?
[laughter]
When I started on "The Office", we had so
many--, John Krasinski--
>>Will: Just a quick thing. So, you're on
this show, "The Office", in which you guys
all play people, you work in this office.
Was that in the script? Or was that something
you came up with on the fly?
[laughter]
So, I, we should take some questions if people
have questions.
>>Rainn: Yeah, good.
>>male #1: Hi, Rainn and Will.
>>Rainn: Hi.
>>male #2: I have a question about heartbreak
and if this is part of the book and what your
take on it is and how it affects the SoulPancake
and if you've gone through it and that kind
of thing. I don't know if that's in scope,
but I hope you have some thoughts on this,
not that I've dealt with this myself.
[laughter]
>>Rainn: Do you, do you have something you
need to get off your chest?
[laughter]
>>male #2: I was just waiting for you guys
to get here, you know? I just got a lot going
on.
>>Rainn: What's her name? What's her name?
>>member #2: My name's Ryan.
>>Rainn: No, what's her name?
>>member #2: Oh, oh.
[laughter]
>>Rainn: Or his name, I don't know.
>>male #2: Kim.
>>Rainn: Really?
>>male #2: No.
[laughter]
This is on YouTube. I can't do that.
>>Rainn: I had, I experienced heartbreak not
far from this building. My first real girlfriend
was named Catherine and Will, actually, was
our roommate and this is in the late '80s.
And, Catherine, she was from New Zealand and
she, she broke up with me and that sucked
and I was heartbroken and she lived on 19th,
we used to live on 19th, between 8th and 9th,
right up here. And then, I stalked her for
a long while because I was sure she was seeing
someone else and I would stand across the
street from her, on the stoop, and I cried
and I wept and I had tears pouring down my
face and I was like, "Why, God, why?" And
it's--
[Rainn laughs]
Will: it was the 6th.
[laughter]
And so, I've experienced heartbreak. Yeah,
sure.
>>male #2: Any advice that you might give
the people? Ok, it's done.
[laughter]
>>Rainn: What doesn't kill you makes you stronger.
Boom. How's that? You can quote me on that.
[laughter]
>>male #3: Hi.
>>Rainn: Hi.
>>male #3: Why do you think there's such a
strong link between funny people and comedians
and wanting to talk about philosophy and large
issues like this?
>>Rainn: Is there?
>>male #3: I think so.
>>Rainn: Is there really? Funny people wanting
to talk about--
>>male #3: It seems like a connection that
I make a lot.
>>Will: Stephen Fry is a good example of that.
>>Rainn: Yeah. Stephen Fry? That's very true.
Stephen Hawking.
[laughter]
Well, I think that there's something to the,
I don't know, it can get, it can sound very
pretentious very easily to talk about comedy
and pain, but you have to know something of
pain to experience comedy or be funny, I think?
Except for Krasinski; I don't think he's ever
had any pain in his life.
[laughter]
And he's a very funny human being. So, that's
all bets are off with him, and ravishly handsome.
[laughter]
Ravishingly.
>>male #3: Does he like philosophy?
>>Rainn: Sorry?
>>Rainn: Nah, I don't think he'd give a rat's
ass about philosophy.
[laughter]
>>Will: I know you don't care what I think,
but I actually--
[laughter]
I haven't thought about this. Not you, but--
>>Rainn: Yeah.
>>Will: but I actually think, when I think
of really funny people that I know, I think
from a very early age, people who know, feel
just some kind of discomfort in life or find
life painful in some way, start to very deeply
need to transform any situation into another
situation, which I think is kind a root of
both philosophy and comedy in a way of--
>>Rainn: Yeah.
>>Will: of seeing a thing and then tilting
it four degrees so that it's another thing.
>>Rainn: I think that there's something to
comedy, too, about, I was always interested
in like, "Why is something funny? Like, that's
really, why is that funny? Why is it funny?"
It wasn't enough for it to just be funny,
and I think that same question of like, "Why
is that funny?" or then it goes to like, "Why
is that true?" or "Why do I feel that way?"
There's that same kind of searching thing.
I know, I don't know. Does that make sense?
Not really. Sorry, I couldn't answer your
question very well.
[laughter]
This is weird.
>>male #4: Hi. I'm a big fan of Krasinski.
>>Rainn: Are you a male model? You a male
model?
>>male #4: No.
[laughter]
>>Rainn: You're in; you're in my Land's End
catalog.
[laughter]
>>male #4: No, I'm not, actually.
>>Rainn: I just saw you. You were selling
a tote bag. Turn around and just go like this.
>>male #4: I left it over on my chair over
there, actually. Sorry. I'm a big fan of the
show and looking for the book, I--
>>Rainn: Of this show?
>>male #4: This show's great. I haven't read
your book, but this makes me interested in
it. But it also, you seem very different then
Dwight Schrute right now and I'm wondering
if you could tell us like, where your motivation
for that character came? It seems different
from Rainn Wilson, so I'd be interested to
know how you, how you developed Dwight Schrute
as a character.
>>Rainn: Umm, yeah. Well, a lot of Dwight
Schrute I stole from the guy who played Gareth
on the English show, who is brilliant, Mackenzie
Crook. And there's, a lot of my family is
kind of trailer trash, South Seattle, muscle
car types, and --
[chuckles]
I really wanted an aspect of that to be part
of Dwight. And I went to high school with
a guy named Chris Cole, who had the same Dwight
glasses and, only they were, they had the
word "Battlestar Galactica" on the sides of
them.
[laughter]
I am not making that up. This is 1980, people.
1980, he had Battlestar Galactica Dwight glasses
back then; he loved fencing, Dungeons and
Dragons, he went into the Army as a coronet
player.
[laughter]
And so I grew up with a lot Dwight.
>>Will: He was actually killed, which was
a sad story.
>>Rainn: What's that?
>>Will: He was decapitated, yeah. Sad story.
>>Rainn: And he was decapitated. No. And he's
killed hundreds of people in wars.
[laughter]
No, not really. But, so, I don't know. I feel
like its part of me; it's part of my roots
and stuff like that and I play Fascists good
and I play nerds good and so I blended the
two and it kinda worked out.
[laughter]
So. Thanks. Good luck with that modeling career.
Yeah?
>>female #1: So, you mentioned that you used
to go to Capitol Hill and rap some philosophy
and I was wondering if you could give us a
demo.
>>Rainn: Umm.
[laughter]
[clapping]
You have that thing? Do you have that thing?
That rap? That one rap? Yeah. It's on my Posterous
account; you can find it. Someone'll look
that up. So, we'll do it. Thanks. Thank a
lot, jerk.
[laughter]
Yeah?
>>female #2: Hi.
>>Rainn: Hi.
>>female #2: I was really gonna try to work
out some sort of soullessness of offices and
trying to bring Google into a really soulful
place, but really, I just wanted to give you
this Droid that we made of Dwight for Halloween.
It's a zombie, so if you wanna talk about
the soullessness of zombies that's fine, too.
>>Rainn: Of zombies? Yeah.
>>female #2: This is for you.
>>Rainn: Why don't zombies eat other zombies?
I mean, they're wandering around-- thank you
very much. This is umm.
[clapping]
They're wandering around; there's plenty of
zombies out there. Do you know what I mean?
Like, just like, they're like "urrrrr." Another
zombie, urrrrr. Why does it, it doesn't make
any sense. Yes.
>>female #3: Hi. How come you didn't ask me
if I'm a model?
[laughter]
>>Rainn: Umm.
>>female #3: No, I'm just kidding. I'm just
kidding. Sorry. So, I think that, as an individual,
it's pretty easy to question religion and
explore lots of different things, but I'm
curious as a parent, how that translates into
raising your kid and how you've chosen to
incorporate that into raising a child?
>>Rainn: Well, that's a very good question.
I think that I learned so much from my son
and I learned so much about what I was talking
about, about being fully engaged in the stuff
of life from my son because he's incapable
of being cynical. He's incapable of being
over something. I mean, I think very soon
they start to experience that as they learn
it from their peers and stuff like that, but
everything that he sees is a little miracle.
I mean, it does, the way cereal floats in
a bowl, the way that this screen is on an
angle, this and how they get the antennas
in there and it, when you have children--most
of you won't because you'll be working your
whole lives--
[laughter]
for Larry and Sergey-- but, I. So, I learn
a ton from him, but I think that I believe
that our--, we owe it to our children to give
them a spiritual education. And that can be
whether you're religious or not, but that
spiritual education is to show them their
place in the universe, teach them about service,
teach them virtues. There are eternal virtues
that work whether you're of a faith, a community,
or not. Kindness, compassion, humility, truthfulness,
all of these things are, need to be fostered
in a child and those are taught best at the
home, not necessarily in schools, although
I think a lot of schools are moving in that
direction and it's a really good thing. And
so, it's very important for me to engage my
son in that, in that spiritual education.
And our, and all of our spiritual education
never stops, really. It's not something like,
"Oh, I have my diploma in my spiritual education."
It continues going, so.
>>female #3: Thank you.
>>Rainn: Umm-hmm. Are you a model?
[laughter]
Don't you work for North Face? Take your hand
off your hip.
[laughter]
>>male #5: Speaking of parenting, I was just
wondering if your wife--
>>Rainn: We're not about to, what?
>>male #5: wondering if your wife is going
to redeem her punch card for four more babies?
>>Rainn: Wait. What?
[laughter]
>>male #5: The joke is dead, nevermind.
>>Rainn: For four more, I don't underst-,
I'm, I wish I knew what that meant.
>>male #5: The Office with Angela.
>>male #6: Angela.
>>Rainn: Ooohh!
[laughter]
Yeah, sit down.
[laughter and clapping]
What do you, what do you work on, man?
>>male #5: On Docs.
>>Rainn: On what?
>>male #5: Google Docs.
>>Rainn: I'm sorry.
[laughter]
Why don't you work on a Google Lasers?
Something really cool; Google Spacecraft.
Google Genetics, Cloning.
[chuckles]
Yes.
>>male #7: Hi. So, you mentioned an interesting
question, which was why are things funny?
How analytically do you approach that? Do
you literally take a joke and rip it apart
and say like, "Oh, this is changed." Or, do
you take a more philosophical approach to
it?
>>Rainn: Well, I think that's the magic of
making art, is that you can philosophize about
it all you want, but then there's the ineffitable,
enethible, intangible thing that happens that
is inexplicable. You can, as a musician; you
can study like, why is something, why is a
melody moving? And you can diagram all these
different melodies and you can write a melody,
but then ultimately it, you gotta hit a point
where it kind of transforms and transcends,
and that's the, what's mysterious about the
arts. And, do you think that's mysterious
about science or computer programming, too?
Does it work that way? Can you figure it all
out with your head or does inspiration and
intuition--there's a life's big question for
you-- does inspiration and intuition guide
anything of what you do when you're programming
or creating something at a place like Google?
Anyone?
>>male #7: Yeah.
>>Rainn: Yeah? How? You would seem to know
the answer to that, I bet.
[laughter]
>>male #7: Strangely enough, I do not.
>>Rainn: You don't. Anyone? Who wants to speak
to that? Yeah?
>>male #6: The people who create programming
languages or programming tools try to that
by letting people express whatever ideas they
have most eloquently or most optimally. So.
>>Rainn: Interesting. You look like, yeah,
you got something to say there. Yeah?
>>male #8: So, we have things like codes,
melds. Like, you take a look at like piece
of code and then like, you realize something
is not, is fishy, but sometimes don't know
exactly what that is.
>>Rainn: Yeah.
>>male #8: And then that's like it's some
sort of intuition you have, like when, at
least like when look at code. We actually
try to formalize those codes, melds so it
becomes more analytical, but there are like,
there is some--
>>Rainn: It's like Keanu Reeves when everything
can turns into numbers, and he's like.
[laughter]
>>male #8: Something like that.
Yeah.
>>male #5: I think it's more like the other
way; you anthropomorphize the code and--oh,
not anthropomorphize--you make it say like,
this part smells bad. That's the way of saying,
"I don't like it," I guess.
>>Rainn: I don't speak any of that language,
but yeah, do you have a question?
>>male #9: Yes, I do. So, you were speaking
about the sense of wonder and that a lot of
musing on philosophy or religion really serves
to answer questions that we cannot answer
adequately through other means. But as the
per view of science and information increases,
these fears of religion or philosophies decreases.
We no longer have to assume that every lightning
bolt falls for a reason and is targeted by
an angry God. So, do you see, perhaps, the
shrinking of the role of religion in our life
as a natural consequence of the expansion
of science? Are we here, as part of Google,
killing wonder by giving people better, real
answers?
>>Rainn: That's an awesome question. Let's
give him an applause for that question.
[applause]
Yeah, I'll speak to that. I'll speak to that.
I think that, first of all, it's a kind of
arrogance to say that religious thought could
be equated to like, "Oh, this angry God threw
a lightning bolt down." I think that that's
really reductivist. I think that if someone
was talking about science and being like,
"Oh, I put a magic thing in a test tube and
nyeh, nyeh, nyeh." No, science can cure cancer
and we can heal people and we can make our
lives easier and better, like we have to be
careful not to reduce both sides of the equation
because I think ultimately religion and science
have to walk hand in hand. And by religion,
I don't mean organized, specific religions.
I mean that again, that thought, that interest
in attuning with the eternal, or with the
divine or transcending; what it is beyond
just being an eating, shitting monkey. And
so, I think that we're in a, our culture is
in a vast change right now. And definitely
science is superseding religion and again,
religion isn't superstition, and that's different
than religion, although certain religions
have superstitious elements still lodged within
them, but I think that as we go forward as
a culture, I think we'll find, first of all,
there's a couple of things that come to mind.
I don't think, and I'm not, I'm not scientist,
but I don't think that science has the explanation
for everything. I think, I think we still
don't know what gravity is. We still don't
know that light, what light is; it's still,
it's a beam, it's a wave, it's a particle,
it's a; we don't know exactly what it is.
You say, "Well, yes it is. It's this form
of--." No, but you can't, you could get the
biggest light expert in the world and they
can't quite tell you. There's something still
not there. We still don't know what the real
building blocks of matter is. I don't think
that science, I don't think that's what science
is, it's providing the concrete answers in
the same way that I don't think religion provides
the concrete answers. So, I think we're in
this phase right now, societally, where science
is on the forefront and it's gonna keep going
and that's great and more and more people
are gonna be like, because you hear people
all the time saying, "I don't believe in religion,
I believe in science." It's like, "Well, ok.
Let's see how science handles those broken
hearts. Let's see how science handles when
someone dies, or when you're grieving. Or
when you feel immense love." Because science
can't answer all of the questions of what
it is to be human. That we, but science is
a beautiful expression of human. I think an
expression of the design. I think God's greatest
creation is science and I think that they
will eventually, if humankind is to survive,
that science and religion will be walking
hand in hand. And not even like, side by side,
but we'll see that they're the same thing.
I think that ultimately that's what it's about;
that art and science and religion, faith,
are all, they're all one thing. Again, it's
that God essence that flows through all of
our molecules that seeks to transcend just
this chair, so. Yeah.
>>Will: Rainn, your parents were driving.
They had set out on a trip to, we should wrap
it up and show the trailer with the [inaudible].
>>Rainn: Oh, ok. Great. One more question
and we'll wrap it up, yeah.
>>male #10: All right. I can't believe I have
to follow that last question, but so, the
premise of The Office is that it's this--
[laughter]
yeah, we're dumbing it down a little bit,
is that this office staff is being filmed
for this ongoing documentary or reality show?
>>Rainn: Yes.
>>male #10: I was just wondering, do the characters
on the show watch this show? And if it hasn't
been released yet, will they?
>>Rainn: Yeah, we talk about that a lot on
"The Office". I think that the documentary
crew just has eternal funding and they have--
[laughter]
two, two camera men and a couple sound guys
and some producers and stuff like that and
they're just like, "Oh my God, I can't believe
all the gold we're getting on this typical
American workplace. Let's just keep filming
and filming and filming and filming." And,
but they did that on the English show, where
on the very tail end of the English show.
The documentary on The Office had aired and
they'd all become minor celebrities. We talk
about heading in that direction in "The Office",
but as soon as you do that, you gotta end
the show. So, I'm not sure exactly when or
how that would happen, but it would be a hell
of a lot of fun. If Dwight Schrute were a
celebrity and you followed Dwight Schrute
around in his life and people were just showing
up at his beet farm asking for autographs
cause they had watched "The Office" and they
just can't believe that such a person exists,
so it's very metaphysical. It's much like
the "SoulPancake" book.
[laughter]
And speaking of that, I hope you'll each pick
up a few dozen copies for stocking stuffers
and let's show that little trailer we made.
>>Will: Do you wanna set it up for them?
>>Rainn: This is a documentary about people
enjoying the "SoulPancake" book.
>>Will: No, I mean could you go back and set
it up for us? Oh, ok.
[electric guitar plays]
[humming]
[applause]
>>Will: All right.
>>Rainn: Is that it? Who's in charge here?
Is that it?
>>Will: We're good?
>>Rainn: Larry, Sergey, are we done?
[laughter]
Thank you guys so much for giving up your
lunch period and having me and Will here.
His new play of Middletown, is at the Vineyard
Theatre. I'm going tonight. You should all
go see it cause he's an absolutely genius
playwright of the first rank and order and
your children will be performing scenes in
drama class from Will Eno plays, so get to
know him now. Tear off a chunk of his sweater
and thank you very much for having me.
[applause]